[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro on est avec vous on est en
direct c'est figaro live et en attend
vos points de vue vos points de vue bien
sûr sur l'allocution du président de la
république à suivre en direct à partir
de 20 heures sur le site et les réseaux
du figaro et figuerola ai-je bien sûr
jusqu'où peut aller mal macron jusqu'où
doit-il sari ou va-t-il s'arrêter dès
expect vent et bien on vous pose la
question et on va la pause est également
à béatrice giblin bonsoir rédactrice en
chef de la revue hérodote donc entre
deux numéros le dernier porte c'est sur
l'afrique médiane et le prochain ce sera
sur le maghreb
c'est ça alors eh bien on élira on déjà
parler du précédent et on parlera du
suivant et on le lira avec profit face à
vous alexis brézet directeur des
rédactions du figaro bonsoir le bon sens
alors le figaro est largement revenu
aujourd'hui sur le dé confinement qui
s'annonce il y reviendra demain et
aujourd'hui on fait ce qu'il est ce
qu'il va dire demande ce qu'il a dit
c'est le journalisme c'est assez simple
finalement les généraux perdre les
guerres en voulant faire des
intelligents disait napoléon vers si je
suis à l'abri de cette de défaut le
figaro qui revient également sur 7 sur
cette polémique qui n'en finit pas
d'enfler autour de la loi sur la
sécurité globale l'article 24 et encore
plus après les violences qui ont été
mari qui ont été émaillées l'évacuation
du camp de migrants installés
illégalement place de la république à
paris on y revient dans une deuxième
partie est d'abord pensez vous qu
emmanuel macron donnera un cap clair sur
le dé confinement et le coronavirus dans
son allocution c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur twitter ce soir c'est la
question qu'on vous pose après avoir lu
l'édito de vincent très divers dans le
figaro de ce jour et après avoir entendu
aussi ceux des demandes aussi bien de
yannick jadot que d'alexis corbières on
les écoute on attend du président de la
république des perspectives ont ré ouvre
les petits commerces et skip révisées
ont ré où les petits commerces étaient
une erreur de les fermer
on a créé des drames qu'on aurait pu
éviter 2 on a une perspective de sur
plusieurs mois de sortie du
déconfinement comment les en les y
compris les étudiants peuvent vous pas
retourner à l'université
il faut penser des alternatives au
confinement va pas passer mon temps est
confiné il faut mais progressivement la
dernière fois ça n'a pas été fait
progressivement en planifiant des choses
moi je suis pour que pour ici on ré
ouvre des commerces avec bien sûr des
protocoles très stricts
qu'est ce que vous attendez justement ce
soir de locutions de béatrice on va dire
on ne peut pas des confiné rapidement
quand on a des confiner la première fois
bas on en n'avait pas l'expérience
voilà après deux mois tout le monde
espérait et puis on allait vers l'été
bon maintenant on sait que c'est pas
comme ça qu'il fallait faire
on ne peut pas supporter un troisième
confinement pour des raisons à la fois
psychologique et économique donc voilà
il va falloir être raisonnable vous avez
été très raisonnable puisque au fond ça
a été très efficace
le confinement cette fois ci un certain
nombre de médecins et d'épidémiologistes
sont même surpris au fond de la rapidité
avec laquelle les choses se sont
améliorées
donc oui on va ouvrir les pieds commerce
ça sera sans doute le week end avant le
1er décembre pour donner un week-end de
plus et puis étalez autant que faire se
peut peut-être qu'ils auront droit
d'ouvrir le dimanche peut-être cela
pourra se faire mais plus tard le soir
enfin bon il y aura sans doute des
aménagements comme ça il faudra
nécessairement des aménagements parce
que si on annonce suit mètre carré par
clignant il ya des tas de boutiques où
il va pas y avoir beaucoup de client
dans la boutique bon donc là il mon avis
y aura une certaine souplesse
assurément on va rouvrir les et les
lieux cultes 1 ça aussi je pense que ça
sera annoncé oui attendait juste finir
pour pour les églises je pense qu'il ya
pas de problème ce que je disais une
fois où on nous en avions parlé
le problème des églises
évangélique sur des petits salles pause
poseront problème soit on met un numerus
clausus son lit bon ben voilà il c'est
la jauge un bon et puis il a offert mais
êtes-vous resté dehors
ouais ça va pas être simple 1 lille ou
chez les chrétiens orthodoxes on a vu
qu'en grèce ça posait des sacrés
problèmes justement jeu je vous écoute
parce que vous nous annoncez quand même
un certain nombre de mesures
jean castex parle de léger
assouplissement au confinement plus que
d'un déconfinement en tant que tel mais
ça c'est que deux et je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse circuler avant peut-être
les vacances de noël moi ce que j'espère
c'est que mac os x
il coûtera pas trop jean castex et coup
droit plus se met elle m'a conquis
depuis le début toujours essayé de peser
dans le sens de l'ouverture et de
l'allègement des contraintes ou du
retardement de la mise en oeuvre des
contraintes j'espère que ce sera ça
j'espère d'abord qui nous dira que ça va
mieux parce que la vérité ça va beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mieux dans des
proportions qui était tout à fait
inattendue dans ton regard de
l'application stop que vides ou tous
contre le coc vide et on en est à 4400
cas c'est ce juste après le week-end
tout à fait sûr c'est qu'on n'avait même
pas à ça mais l'année le taux le r là il
est à 0,65
donc ça veut dire que le nom comme ça à
chaque génération mais dix jours sans
doute encore plus bas à paris voilà à
paris encore plus bas et on est en
dessous du xiii en dessous du seuil de
la tannerie tous déjà il faut nous dire
que ça va mieux après nous dira que
c'est grâce aux mesures que nous avons
appris en soldes war ne pas le croire
c'est pas du tout sûr gens présents que
je passe un peu tous pareils et en même
temps ça monte partout ça passe partout
mais bon à la limite partout devant des
mesures aussi donc oui bon on a le
maillot n'a pas du tout pris les mêmes
mesures en espagne à un moment il ya les
bons livres ça fait la fête les boîtes
de nuit sont verts égal à la limite peu
importe l'essentiel c'est que ça aille
mieux
donc ce premier point d'eux qu'ils nous
disent à quel mais dans quelle vitesse
vont aller le faire de déconfinement et
ce que j'espère c'est que ça valait le
plus vite possible
donc oui dès ce week-end et dès ce
samedi les commerces les cultes et
j'espère qu'on va sinon faire sauter ce
qui serait idéal
en tout cas élargir l'autorisation de
circulation qu'on sorte de yves d une
heure qu'on sorte de du kilomètre
donc est-ce que entre une heure et quand
on veut et 1 km et tout ce qu'on veut on
va pas trouver un truc entre les deux ça
me paraît pas impossible en tout cas et
puis ensuite il nous annoncera la 2e
étape où on ouvrira sûrement les
non non bâle les restaurants les
sandwichs oui je pense que le restaurant
ça sera plutôt en janvier la deuxième la
deuxième étape
ça sera sorte me semble semble-t-il de
passer un couvre-feu après le
confinement est peut-être lé théâtre les
spectacles cinéma ce qui serait qui
serait à la mi-décembre pour pour noël
etc et donc on le vrai le confinement
pour noël laissant un couvre-feu mais ça
permettra aux gens de se retrouver en
famille pour lé là on ferait sauter les
distances des distances et puis après
restera il sera mi janvier pour faire
les restaurants et les bars ont en effet
en les frappant les salles de sport et
l'espagne de sport je sais pas quoi te
fais moi ce que j'espère c'est qu'on
n'ira le plus vite possible et la
troisième chose que j'espère c'est que
ils nous disent aussi une fois qu'il
nous aura dit que vraiment tous très
bien faire qu'ils ont été formidables ok
maintenant bien qu'il puisse maintenant
ce qu'on va faire pour éviter de se
payer une troisième vague note est sûre
avec deux points importants le premier
pour l'éviter
des vagues ses traces et testé isolé
qu'est-ce qu'on va réussir à mettre en
place qu'on n'a pas réussi à mettre en
place entre les deux premières balles
parce que c'est une deuxième vague c'est
bien qu'il ya des trucs qu'on n'a pas
bien fait entre la première et la
deuxième est l'autre point sur lequel on
l'attend pour la suite c'est les vaccins
comment redistribuer à qui on a
distribué qu'est-ce qui est mise en
oeuvre pour que d'un point de vue
logistique on sache
acheminer et distribuer gérer la
distribution des vaccins alors juste sur
sur les perspectives et sur le
calendrier que vous avez vous avez
défini donc il ya castex qui est lui a
peur également dorée des réveillons qui
sont des usines à kovy jo le site est
alors il ya la peur également pour noël
et ça c'est plutôt côté médical je vais
vous faire écouter ce que dit ce matin
le président de la commission médicale
des hôpitaux de paris qui est le
professeur rémy salomon au sujet du
réveillon de noël
et j'aimerais bien avoir votre réaction
enfin du réveillon ou du jour de noël du
coup
donc on peut aller chez papi et mamie à
noël on ne mange pas avec eux on coupe
la bûche de noël en deux papys et mamies
manche dans la cuisine et nous on mange
dans la salle à manger
c'est des choses aussi ça non mais c'est
pareil on va manuel même à noël parce
que même si on a pris les précautions
avant on peut quand même avoir un des
fois c'est plus que c'est ce que sept
jours le la période d'incubation
si si je transmet le virus a passé lire
in blue c'est pire que tout comme enjeu
comment je vais vivre ça après parce que
papy mamie ils ont un risque sérieux de
d'être en réanimation et d
éventuellement d'en mourir
alors papis et mamies t'emmerde ça c'est
la réaction notre confrère jean sevilla
sur sur twitter est-ce que vous avez la
même réaction que notre confrère qui est
historiquement à correct on reprendre la
formule ou bien vous irez à la cuisine à
bachir et certainement pas à la cuisine
ça alors c'est hors de question
de deux choses l'une où on fait noël et
on demande à nos enfants et petits
enfants et pas d'être testé rapidement
avant puisque maintenant c'est possible
et auquel cas il arrive non avec un test
négatif où ils ont un test positif et
ils ne viennent pas géré à partir du
moment où on réunit en wallon ne sera
pas 24 chez moi on sera 8
voilà mais on sera 8 on mettra une
grande table mais on sera 8 et on sera
tous tous ensemble et je vais dire c'est
scandaleux de garons couplet du chant de
étaient grands parents à la cuisine et
enfin se lancer
sachez quand même grotesque un truc
pareil enfin ça n'a aucun sens dont donc
avec sont un peu plus de ces gens qui
nous disent comment doit vivre enfin
possible quoi écouter non non ne les
affligés c'est énervant
il ya quelque chose qui n'avait acquis
tom les sétois contrôle mais là je vous
ai expliqué qu' il fallait pas déjeuné
avec ses enfants rappelez vous c'était
il ya quinze jours trois semaines vous
c'est pas grave vous enfants viennent à
la maison ou les fêtes déjeuner à bord
non mais qu'est ce que c'est tout ça et
castex il nous parle d' usine à kovy
dont parle pas des fêtes de nouvelles
comme une usine à qu'ovide on fait telle
région c'est un réveillon du transfert
d'une équipe qui disent que ça puisse
être un constat et puis voilà mais on
n'a pas de nom mais dieu que deux
espèces de supériorité technocratique
parce qu'ils me ce qui m'inquiète un peu
c'est par exemple ce qu'il ya eu dans le
13e sur une voie désaffectée où et avec
une grosse tête avec plus de 300
personnes samedi soir
je suis même pas si ça a été sanctionné
ou pas d'ailleurs où la deuxième samedi
à joinville le pont dans la même maison
où on a recommencé
la l'utiliser en boîte de nuit bon moi
ça me
ça m'agace beaucoup parce que d'une
certaine façon quand il ya 300 personnes
ensemble bon ben oui oui et après ces
gens vont aller dans l'armée c'est
l'immunité collective dans l'humilité
collective il y aura des gens âgés comme
moi bon qu'ils se trompent de droit mais
pour le jeu comme ça mais bon le moment
c'est pas comme ça quand on dit les
français sont adultes ce sont des
citoyens donc on leur fait confiance
enfin il n'y a donc pas à 30 ans vous
êtes encore un enfant
eh ben mon dieu reconnaissez qualifié le
groupe médiatique sur ces trucs là bien
sûr c'est pas bien où le la mais c'est
très très très très très minoritaire
dans l'ensemble le confinement le
couvre-feu 2012 est très bien respectée
d'ailleurs les résultats sont bons rien
et qui respectent pas la règle ou
heureusement ça prouve qu'on est encore
français juste puisque l'on parle de
jeunes les facs les universités votre
avis il faut les rouvrir ses vitres à
moi je serais pour au moins à la moitié
en présentiel la moitié en d'essentiel
si mais je pense qu'il faut ouvrir les
universités si on rouvre pas les nude
universités on va avoir un décrochage
extrêmement important d'une grande en
particulier des première et deuxième
années après en licence en master les
choses sont déjà mieux s'installer mais
là il faudra absolument faire une
infiniti fifty si vous voulez au moins
et j'ajouterais que dans les lycées où
on a créé c'est sur deux demi groupes
qui marchent pas bien de toute façon il
n'y a pas assez de profs ya passé de
s'allier à passer de le plus vite on
arrivera à reprendre les cours dans leur
fonctionnement normal le mieux ce sera
fish qui allez christophe 78,2 dit
encore trois heures de suspense avant de
savoir si nous allons bénéficier d'une
sortie anticipée de notre confinement
est effectivement ce sera à suivre en
direct christophe sur le site du figaro
un cap clair j'en doute fort nous dit
nicole effectivement c'est la question
qu'on pose sur twitter d'ailleurs pensez
vous qu emmanuel macron donnera un cap
clair sur le déconfinement alcorn un
virus dans son allocution ars qui était
assez drôle
que dans les réactions à la question
qu'on avait posé il ya beaucoup de gens
qui nous ont dit mais pourquoi vous
poser cette question maintenant mais je
shoote comme j'aimerais qu'il ya quand
même quatre cents personnes qui ont
répondu et une majorité qui est
sceptique et j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi vous êtes sceptique alors
peut-être comme christophe il va encore
parler 30 minutes pour donner des
informations qui pourraient se
communiquer en trois minutes
macron doit ré ouvrir les commerces sis
dans son bilan économique se raplomber
nous d'hiver du lot et nous n'avons
toujours aucune preuve que les
confinements ait eu le moindre impact
nous dit rustice est pas votre avis non
c'est pas du tout mon avis chez la vie
d'un de mes petits-fils par exemple vous
le dire mais moi c'est pas du tout mon
avis je pense que là le web bien sûr la
rapidité du résultat quand même montre
que réduire la circulation des gens
c'est réduire la circulation du virus
c'est le télétravail c'est diminuer le
nombre de gens dans le métro c'est
diminuer les gens dans toute forme de de
circulation entre un avion ou autre ça
des effets et ça aussi un effet jadis
psychologique c'est de permettre sa d'un
nombre de membres de la population de
prendre conscience qu'il faut faire
attention
autrement si on laisse aller bon bah
voilà c'est pas grave et et on va
refaire ce que ce qu on a fait cet été
donc oui moi je pense que le confinement
a été a été utile et je dirais que dans
tout l'est dans tous les pays on a pris
des mesures qui sont pas forcément le
confinement mais on appelait les mesures
on les a prises en grande bretagne on
les a prises en allemagne aux apprise en
belgique mais si on voulait pas dire
qu'on ait sa place est très très très
très très beau coup mais l'allemagne
n'avait pas été touchée comme nous
l'avions été l'allemagne ce qu'il
fallait c'est moi qui me paraît frappant
c'est que l'allemagne réussit à voir
quatre fois moins de morts que la france
et j'ajouterai une diminution de sa
croissance moitié moindre que nous on va
perdre 12 % de pib
les allemands vont perdre 5 6% c'est
colossal dire que l'écart dans cette
affaire alors on se gargarise disant
qu'on a très bien géré la faire mais
quand on se compare à l'allemagne on se
rend compte que que l'écart entre la
france et l'allemagne que ce soit en
termes de l'irb en arbitres la santé et
l'économie non
père sur les deux tableaux la santé on a
quatre fois plus de morts l'économie en
a deux fois plus de deux fois une
croissance c'est catastrophique aurait
pu perdre encore plus sûres harper et de
côté et puis on vous prenez l allemagne
comme jauge bon si je regarde la grande
bretagne
bon et bien on est beaucoup plus proche
de la grande bretagne et la grande
bretagne est beaucoup plus proche de
nous ou si je regarde l'italie à la même
façon qu'on se console pas mieux de ré
avec ce qui réussit mais c'est à dire
qu'on a passé son temps à se flageller
en disant on est mauvais on est mauvais
et moselle comme à bayeux que des
erreurs ont été commises ces c'est bien
évident c'est sûr et le modèle allemand
moi je n'ai aucune envie d'avoir
l'histoire de l'allemagne dont je
continue à de nombreuses séries telles
que vous êtes jeune et bien voilà c'est
dit cette maman de provocation disait je
veux pas venir chinois où je veux pas
devenir co rien on passe encore mais pas
devenir allemand mais jouez pas le mien
j'ai dit que j'avais pas envie de leur
histoire à peu près de consensus entre
ce plateau je suis pour la fin du
confinement mais je mets pour un
couvre-feu à partir de 22h ou 23h nous
dit on y colle alors ça sera peut-être
ce qui sera annoncé ce soir et
christophe de demain que le coup
pourquoi c'est pas pour ça s'est passé
pour ce soir c'est pour un peu plus tard
un peu plus tard alors christophe par
contre et sont d'accord avec vous il dit
va nous expliquer comme emmanuel macron
que nous avons été bien obéissants car
maison nous n'avons pas une 9000
personnes en réanimation mais si déjà
ils nous disaient que collectivement les
français se sont bien comportées ont
fait des efforts et que ce qui se passe
est le fruit de leurs efforts ça serait
déjà bien
s'il éviter de nous dire c'est grâce au
magnifique magnifique politique que le
gouvernement qui a fait de lui des
efforts et c'est grâce au gouvernement
s'ils le disent et les français déjà sa
magnifique un grand progrès par rapport
à ce qu'on a entendu pendant longtemps
où chaque fois le le
ministre arrive en disant c'est grâce à
moi que vous allez mieux ben non c'est
grâce à nous non ils disent pas que ça
je suis pas d'accord avec vous non je
suis pas d'accord avec vous c'est plus
de temps était plutôt à le dire le thème
les français ont fait n'importe quoi cet
été les français nous avons fait nous
nous c'est nous oui mais où nous sommes
et le gouvernement fait n'importe quoi
est ce que franchement alexis est ce que
cet été ainsi on avait dit aux jeunes
vous allez pas danser vous allez pas
faire si vous n'allez pas faire ça et c
est ce que c'était audible même pour
nous est-ce que c'était aux dit bourdais
bref je sais il faut pas leur reprocher
d'avoir dansé ce moment là si on leur a
pas dit qu'il fallait pas danser non si
ça a été dit à partir de la mi-août et
bassement leur appartement on attend
c'est à dire les choses les gens l'ont
fait non mais sinon j'ai reçu sur ma g
baca et non allez toujours je saute pas
n'est pas reproché des gens français et
s'exonérer soi même quand on est
gouvernants et qu'on est finalement élu
payé pour faire les choses c'est un peu
trop commode me semble-t-il
il est allé citoyenne ne sont pas là
pour faire les règles les citoyens sont
là dedans les respecte pour les
respecter à condition qu'elle soit
claire et pas trop belle et à condition
qu'ils allaient s'en fait pas trop et
ben oui donc il faut pas s'étonner qu'il
ait raté mettre d'accord françois nous
demande pour être enfin abandonner cette
règle du kilomètre on l'espère mais pas
forcément ce soir et parions sur 20 ou
le gouvernement doit doit sortir le re
du registre de la peur nous dit babineau
et christophe 78 ironise sur les
injonctions donc du professeur salomon
rémy salomon a pas jérôme simplement sur
la bûche que l'on doive que les grands
parents doivent prendre à la à la
cuisine c'est la meilleure excuse pour
ne pas avoir sa belle-mère à la table de
noël
la question qu'on vous savez chez elle
ben voilà c'est la question parce que la
cuisine
pensez vous qu emmanuel macron donnera
un cap clair sur le dé confinement et le
coronavirus dans son allocution
mais pour l'instant c'est donc toujours
le scepticisme qui l'emportent avec 74 %
de non être
un point ce sera un autre débat mais
kris kross qui nous dit il aurait fallu
fermer les frontières dès le départ et
c'est pas su voir ça c'est sûr emmanuel
macron l'annoncent ce soir c'est sûr
c'est sûr qu'en partant en asie dans
tous les pays
alors il ya la discipline y de ces
populations l'autodiscipline qui souvent
est moins imposés au taux imposé mais
aussi les fermetures des frontières vous
allez aujourd'hui à singapour en corée
au vietnam
vous faites une quarantaine de 15 jours
ou de huit jours à l'hôtel mais
n'empêche qu'ils aillent au vietnam et
75 cas où les autres deux autres
éléments 1
la corée taïwan ou autres ont
l'expérience d'avoir eu une une pandémie
c'est le mans et puis quand un virus aux
autres virus respiratoires aussi donc il
savait pas ce que la première fois ils
ont eu beaucoup de dégâts
ils en ont tiré les leçons et ça se
passe beaucoup mieux elle au deuxième
quart deuxièmement c'est quand même des
dpi dans l'histoire de la corrèze
jusqu'à un passé pas si les récents avec
un régime extrêmement autoritaire non
démocratique ça a été bien évidemment le
cas du vietnam encore aujourd'hui c'est
moins le cas de taiwan pour moi ta
éloigner le plus exemplaire d'une
certaine façon parce que juste en face
de vous souvenez quand même ne nous a
pas expliqué qu'il fallait pas fermer
les frontières parce que les virus
ignorait les frontières mais oui on nous
l'a dit savez mes bien chers bambins
s'étaient élevées au quai du monde on
nous a dit qu'il fallait pas porter de
masque parce que le masque était
dangereux on a fait un procès au maire
de cannes david lisnard
et oui parce qu'ils distribuent des
masques que ça veut dire donc on peut
dire non oui ça serait utile mais on le
fera pas parce que c'est pas dans nos
traditions
mais dire c'est inutile et c'est
dangereux c'est un mensonge et je pense
que ça tient aussi à une situation dire
qu'on ferme et des frontières s'étaient
je dis pas qu'ils avaient raison c'était
se mettre sur le front d'un discours et
ça on ne voulait absolument me voulait
absolument pas 30 ce discours de la
fermeture des frontières qui aurait
donné aurait rendu évidemment
rassemblement national jubilatoire bien
évidemment on vous l'a toujours dit et
c'est je pense que c'est un élément
c'est l'autre polémique du jour
l'évacuation plus que mouvementée du
camp de migrants place de la république
à paris hier soir alors les images ont
choqué on avait des croche-pieds sur les
migrants des journaliste molesté gérald
darmanin a dit lui-même qu'il était
choqué cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale
il a demandé un rapport au préfet de
police
l'allemand
il saisit l'egypte l'igpn beaucoup de
voix y compris dans la majorité ont
demandé au premier ministre de remiser
la loi sur la sécurité globale et en
particulier l'article 24 sur la
diffusion des images de policiers
et voici ce que le pont du jean castex
cet après midi à l'assemblée pour que ne
subsiste
mesdames et messieurs pour que ne
subsiste aucun doute sur notre ferme
intention d'assurer l'indispensable
protection de nos forces de sécurité
dans lanthier respect de nos libertés
démocratiques et de l'état de droit
je vous annonce que je saisirai moi même
le conseil constitutionnel sur l'article
24 au terme du processus législatif
alors est ce que cette saisine du
conseil constitutionnel et de est de
nature à rassurer de sauver cette loi 24
est bon s'il annonce qu'il va saisir le
conseil constitutionnel c'est peut-être
à l'avant même que le disposition soit
votée ça veut dire qu'il ya que le
gouvernement lui-même un doute sur une
mesure qu'il est censé défendre
donc c'est ouvrir la porte elle imite
demander conseils comme celle de la
censurer et à mon avis ils vont pas se
faire
un premier vote à l'assemblée puis un
deuxième vote au sénat puis un troisième
incendie puis un quatrième sénat pour la
femme de négoce émotionnelle qui veulent
retoqué je pense que là c'est la
première étape de quelques 2 2 d'un
processus où cet article 24 va s'enliser
dans l'est la procédure prend la main
ça vous quel est votre point de vue est
ce que ce que dit le justement parce que
j'en lis sont concernés par cet article
est-ce que c'est rassurant est-ce que
c'est sécurité globale notamment des
réductions de peine réduite pour les
gens qui ont agressé les policiers les
pompiers
le fait pour les policiers devoir sortir
et qu'une arme de service les sert donc
de faciliter pour les polices
municipales et plein de choses très bien
je pense que c'est un petit 24 est
absolument inutile inutiles qui a déjà
huit disposition dans nos lois qui
permettent de de réprimer les atteintes
aux policiers comme dire à tout le monde
donc on va y revenir mais c'est inutile
au mieux c'est inutile au pire c'est
dangereux alors je veux bien qu'on me
dise que c'est pas dangereux mais en
tout cas il reste que c'est inutile
à quoi bon aller chercher des ennuis
pour un truc inutile je pense que tout
ça depuis le début' absurde je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec alexis là
dessus je pense que c'est une affaire
qui n'est pas simple j'ai eut pris le
temps d'aller regarder comment ça se
passait ailleurs pour savoir si cette
possibilité de mettre sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'en fait c'est ça des
petits films de policiers en train de
réprimer une manifestation en belgique
après un débat qui a duré quand même
quelques années c'est possible de la
même façon
en allemagne c'est selon les länder dans
le brandebourg fond on peut en rhénanie
du nord on ne peut pas bon donc il n'y a
pas une loi commune si vous voulez en
angleterre il ya un organisme à part
qu'ils étudient effectivement les vidéos
ou autres on les met pas directement
mais donc il y avait il ya vraiment un
débat sur quelque chose qui est
compliqué qui est difficile moi je pense
qu'il ya déjà normalement en france en
2014 a été pris une décision comme quoi
les policiers les gendarmes devaient
avoir leur matricule visible le fameux
rio bon or il est très souvent jamais
porté surtout par la police beaucoup
moins par les gendarmes
quand il est porté il est illisible soit
mis un endroit où ferons peut pas le
voir
soit il est tout usé et on peut pas le
voir et je me suis interrogé sur est ce
qu'il ya des sanctions si on ne respecte
pas ça aucune sanction
depuis 2014 n'a été mise là dessus moi
ça me pose quand même un problème parce
que si on est j'ai dit au clair avec soi
même et si son comportement n'est pas
répréhensible
on doit pouvoir être identifiés et je
pense que cette idée du matricule
françois hollande avait demandé le
récépissé s'est jamais passé donc on est
passé au matricule matricule qui a en
allemagne qui a en angleterre qui a des
tas d'endroits
donc on pouvait ce qu'elle est là dessus
et je trouve ça gênant qui puisse ne pas
le porter qu'il n'y ait aucune sanction
à ce sujet voilà ce qui veut dire que on
pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'on sache pas
tout du comportement de la police et et
la confiance dans la police est
absolument indispensable
oui mais la confiance dans la police
notre côté aujourd'hui la crise elle est
par exemple beaucoup plus élevé que je
pense par exemple la confiance dans les
journalistes
oui parce qu'on est sur quelques faits
pas chialer beaucoup plus élevé tout est
peint on peut d milieu dans lequel on y
va bon mais le peloton mais moins que
les pompiers mais bon mais néanmoins
elle devrait être totale voilà sur les
journalistes bon bah vous avez
heureusement il ya encore des tas de
gens qui font confiance aux journalistes
mais bon c'est ont toute information est
maintenant prise en défaut contestée et
contestable
bon le complotisme à tout-va etc et
c'est bien mais la raison n'est plus
tellement présente géza certain nombre
de nos concitoyens cela dit qu'il
fallait protéger les policiers qu'en
terme de délation en ligne d'apple allen
en ligne de données on a les outils
alors c'est ce que je vais dire
oui c'est nécessaire donc absolument et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on est
policier quand on est même femmes de
policiers enfants de policiers on peut
se retrouver pris à partie avec son
adresse désigné l'école des enfants
désignés les policiers suivent donc
c'est c'est une vie qui peut être
difficile
donc ça il faut le prendre en compte
mais on a les instruments juridiques
les menaces sont 100 sont prévues par le
code pénal les atteintes à la vie privée
sont des deux reprises par le code pénal
des injures sont réprimés par le code
pénal les appels à la haine sont
réprimés par le code pénal est et côté
vie le cyber harcèlement et réprimer et
la responsabilité pénale des réseaux
sociaux est engagé c'est ce que dit kris
kross le travail de facebook de bloquer
la diffusion des noms alors un autre
sourire ça c'est encore autre chose mais
quoi qu'il en soit on a déjà tout un pas
de tir après reste à le mettre en oeuvre
mais ce n'est pas en prenant une règle
de plus pour l'interdire qu on le mettra
mieux en oeuvre ça changeait donc le
panel on l'a il se trouve qu'on le fait
pas pour qu'on le fait pas d'abord ce
que sans ça il ya un manque de moyens de
la justice d'en engager des poursuites
et à manque de courage politique qui
fait que quand des policiers sont on
n'ose pas aller attaquer pierre paul
jacques qui souvent sous couvert
d'anonymat
le fond sur les réseaux sociaux encore
faut-il des attaques et si on les
attaquait on a les moyens de les
poursuivre après faut arriver à faire
retirer par les raids des réseaux
sociaux
le ski ce qu'ils ont postés là encore on
le peut on y allait mal il faut le
demander
il faut les poursuivre l'anonymat alors
je reconnais qu'il ya un vrai sujet qui
est celui de l'anonymat sur les restes
jolie les gaffes à se défendre mordicus
parce que leur modèle économique repose
beaucoup sur l'anonymat et à certains
nombres de 2,2 dupond-moretti par
exemple de vous deux au congrès ont
vraiment bizarre mais c'est important
l'anonymat ça permet à des défenseurs
des donneurs là l'air de dire sans ce
sens va être mis en cause par le
rendrait président saison ce qui est
vrai il n'empêche que le temps quand on
veut poursuivre quelqu'un le temps
d'obtenir la levée de l'année le temps
de lever l'anonymat le temps d'aller
trouver le gars quand on le trouve et
c'est le le poste a fait a fait son
choix
donc là je reconnais qu'il ya vrai bien
vrai sujet mais cet exploit
ne prévoit pas du tout de réprimer la
venue à ce texte là prévoit de répéter
pour la dixième fois qu'on n'a pas le
droit d'appeler à l'aide de désigner les
policiers à la vindicte et met dans le
même sac les journalistes professionnels
qui font leur travail avec les cerezo
citoyens machin truc qui très souvent
sous couvert de démarcher vic mettant en
accusation les policiers mais c'est
parfois ça a été utile aussi bon cd tous
les tous les comportements des policiers
ne sont pas irréprochables
on peut pas dire ça je ne mets pas tous
les deux le même sac mais il est évident
que pour certains on va avoir une
réaction va dire au delà du raisonnable
et je pense qu'on de voix beaucoup plus
se préoccuper de la formation sérieuse
de nos policiers de véritablement de
façon à ce qu'on soit très exigeant et
qu'il soit exemplaire mabille on est
policier on doit être exemplaire c'est
certain ce malheureux c'est que ce alors
que le dispositif ait l'intention du
gouvernement c'est de mettre l'accent
sur la protection des policiers
on en vient à cause des maladresses de
ce projet de loi
des maladresses du ministre parlait qui
a commencé à parler de floutage donc
c'est pas prévu dans la loi
j'ai commencé à parler de ceux
répertoriés devant le devant de la
profession la 200e et et les maladresses
delà de l'application de l'ordre public
dans la sphère de la placer et plus de
maladresse en maladresse on en vient
maintenant transformer ça en procès des
policiers à dire il faut qu'il se rendre
des comptes c'est le point de départ
c'était de les protéger notamment dans
les affaires de terrorisme et
d'islamisme contrats sont donc de mener
d'officine qui passent leur temps à les
dénoncer
le ces beaux résultats franchement
c'était pas la peine on a du mal à
comprendre quand même étant donné le
contexte que
[Musique]
les accusations justement ils ont porté
la toute l'attention que l'évacuation
tous les cas la façon dont cela s'est
passé l'allemand qui a pris sur lui en
disant bon c'est une provocation
d'installer les 1 100 tentes sur la
place de la république ce samedi à ce
titre d'autres médecins sans frontières
bon ils les ont amenés pour remettre ces
de provocation assumée d'assumer mes
yeux mais pour le remettre sur le devant
de la scène médiatique et qu'on en parle
bon et l'allemand a eu une réaction
extrêmement vive
il semblait assez rigide de le préfet de
police de paris
bon et hop il a dit vous me débarrasser
ça en deux temps trois se sont gravement
mais l'évidence il est tombé dedans des
militants professionnels des activistes
qui deux élus comment des élus mais mais
mais bon et que c'est une démarche
politique mais c'est un piège bon on
n'est pas obligé de se jeter tête
baissée dans tous les pièges à limited
attendait 2 jours 3 jours que ça montre
que l'énervement des riverains montrent
que imane hidalgo 10e quand même un
problème on va d'accord on va les
évacuer puisque vous le demander enfin
des évolutions us ou sarkozy n'a eu
soulignait déjà qu'on a tout le temps
mais on n'est pas melloul au moment où
on est en train de voter cette loi qui
est déjà très contesté alors que tant
d'autres c'est plus qu'une maladresse
cela dit l'allemande match serait pas et
n'a pas lancé l'opération tout seul
non il a évidemment demander
l'autorisation ministre sachant je suis
pas vous êtes peut-être nous armer
comment on se voit une information donc
je cherche je n'en sais rien c'est mal
et je ne serais pas étonné que le préfet
l'allemande ça se passe très très longue
carrière à son poste et on continuera de
suivre ça en attendant je vous donne
rendez vous à 20h pour une autre
question c'est celle du confinement de
déconfinement qui a qu'un pacte un peu
aussi le préfet l'allemand et puisqu'il
s'est quand même les attestations mais à
la marge les reconnaître qu'ils nous
fichent plutôt la paix c'est qu'on est
un peu plus surveillé qu'à d'autres
alors c'est vrai que non sur le coup sûr
le confinement le truc qui franchement
ils fichent la plonge c'est ce qu'on a
pu observer entre nous dans sa tente
dans certains quartiers de paris
merci beaucoup merci de nous avoir
suivis alors je vous pose et on vous
poser la question sur twitter la loi sur
la sécurité globale doit-elle être
adopté en l'état et vous répondez non à
59%
vous êtes un peu plus partagés merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
avec guillaume roquette et donc 20
heures la locution des mâles macron à
suivre en direct sur figure live
[Musique]